[Musique]
C'est en fait absolument génial d'
avoir l'opportunité de danser dans la
Galerie des Glaces où l'histoire était autrefois
partout où vous touchez et partout où vous
voyez, c'est vivre l'histoire et c'est
vraiment une chose phénoménale de pouvoir
faire
[Musique]
J'adore  nous
honnêtement, je pense que nous ne pouvons pas nier que nous
vivons aujourd'hui donc aussi le psy est un mélange
du passé, du présent et du
futur donc je pense que nous devrions rassembler
tout cela et je suis très sûr que si Marie
Antoinette vivrait aujourd'hui elle
aurait aussi des cils au laser elle
aurait des paillettes je suis très sûr qu'elle
ne le saura juste pas
[Musique] [
Musique]
es-tu prête
euh
la personne costumes
[Musique]
voici le 400ème anniversaire de
Versailles  donc nous devons célébrer avec
du champagne